на кону
активи у Європи до тиснув на в'їзд до
євросоюзу
і зація віктор янукович toyota дуже
активно бореться
майже всі 17 українських фігурантів
чорному списку падав і поза ви через
порушення їх прав санкції 2014 року
суд у люксембурзі вже вона lvov я як
треба вт одним ґрунтування адже вже навіть
просто радою з собою а заново холод і за
повага до суду подібна до інею неправомірних
сансі ще нарік мати бо на слід комусь
ще позову чесно повернуться до нас їм
основу вона улюблена санкції
алеф же за civic fd coles
суду витя а нині каррі лист у євросоюзі
травня заводячи чого ти
українській владі двору до цього кидали а
волосся та санкції проти команди віктора
януковича на 1 їжі на вал і
став генеральною прокуратурою України я
не надто до суду люксембурзі
праворуч протикав зайвих українців високо
пасодобль у нас правді порушила флеша
через Європу
що одна пара ставить люксембурзького
суду брюса юна потреба
там у нових values ​​анти ширше тільки у
над їх калашником українських чиновників у
tucson на цих українах за два роки і так
мало форма лева ти та висоти офісі не
обману vaccine
генеральна прокуратура України побачити
нашого розводять руками і заявляю ще в
жайна дала брюсселю значить серйозний
обладнання для продовження санкцій
а за дрібною українською води ти по
роздуми розплачуйтеся
європейський мандрівники податливий потрапив
доїсть забув я за на компенсувати і з
зручний ви витрачаєте кум його на прожила
позу ви клімату вовка лиж не українські
чиновники може ви мати чай у рушницю
виття компенсації та dc про так звану
фінансового вигляду побачилися з аварією
закон у європейському союзі його
встановимо це інституціями
хоч одне сими на свято чал і грушевих
компенсацію довідок санкцій у гаю на
ланцюги йдуть загартованого бюджету
європейського союзу то найбільшу
працювати іншу просту для України стани
рішення суду Європейського Союзу
влаштую віктора януковича який відсікають
на початку літа явні сліди чорному
списку над їх самих підставок сіра штук
цьому санкції за поза махнув ерік
лиж йому українському президентові на йому
бачиш і вона любить